[Musique]
deux policiers ont été blessés par
balles hier soir à herblay dans le val
d'oise après avoir été agressé par trois
individus qui leur ont volé leur arme de
service
ils ont ensuite ouvert le feu avec ses
armes le mot roué de coups et trop léger
massacre est littéralement ces deux
policiers pendant un moment où ils ont
ensuite pris leurs armes pour tirer
manifestement à sept reprises et 6 fois
les ballons touchés
les policiers dont un je voudrais ici de
dire se bat pour la vie je rappeler que
c'est le quotidien de la vie des
policiers et des gendarmes des pompiers
parfois que d'être menacés ont besoin de
passer la période de la rentrée scolaire
bas nous il ya des policiers qui nous
ont dit à mon petit garçon de 8 ans il
ose pas dire à l'école que son papa et
policiers parce que sinon il va être
menacés des pompiers qui déposent leurs
casques à terre hier devant les
barrières de la préfecture une manière
pour eux d'exprimer leur ras-le-bol face
aux violences répétés qu'ils subissent
comme on sait toujours on prend son nous
on a besoin on avait simplement donné
manquera qui le pressent principal
aujourd'hui c'est de pouvoir arrêter les
auteurs de ces actes ignobles de les
confondre
et comme l'a évoqué lui même le garde
des sceaux ce matin devrait adresser
évidemment mon mon soutien à ces hommes
à leur famille l'ensemble des policiers
c'est un drame insupportable et on
espère bien sûr que les coupables seront
arrêtés et jugés aujourd'hui une plainte
est déposée tous les deux jours
de plus en plus les pompiers sont
victimes de guet-apens de faux appels au
secours pour les attirer et s'en prendre
à eux
malheureusement monsieur le président de
la république a nommé a misé de la
justice qui n'a pas véritablement un
esprit je dirais qu'il va véritablement
dans le sens de la répression il ya
encore beaucoup de progrès à faire dans
le sens de la prise de conscience et si
les hautes autorités de l'état n'ont pas
conscience de ce qui est en train de se
passer actuellement d'ailleurs qu'ils
font reprendre véritablement main dans
ces territoires il faut il faut
intervenir massivement pour combattre
cette délinquance qui est une forme
d'insurrection quotidiennes contre les
forces de l'ordre
je pense que nous allons au devant de
lendemains qui vont être extrêmement
difficile je pense marine le pen c'est
la baguette magique et la matraque en
même temps
qui peut sérieusement penser que le jour
où par malheur ce qu'à dieu ne plaise
elle est présidente de la république les
crimes s'arrête dans notre pays
enfin c'est une plaisanterie je pense
donc que c'est une bénédiction de dieu
que je les attraper c'était un mal pour
un bien
je veux que vous ayez ce que j'ai reçu
et je vais le rendre gratuit vous
n'allez pas payés pour ça ce n'est pas
votre faute si c'est arrivé c'est la
faute de la chine et la chine va en
payer le prix fort
proudfoot suffit pour une mouche qui est
pendant de la rue s'est longuement posé
sur la chevelure blanche de mike pence
il ne s'en est pas rendu compte mais sur
twitter c'est déjà évidemment il ya déjà
beaucoup de dessins elle vote by john
harris f
la situation sanitaire en france
continue de se dégrader une nouvelle
fois le ministre de la santé demande à
chacun d'être extrêmement vigilant
notamment lors des rassemblements
familiaux
même si vous recevez votre famille vos
enfants vos petits enfants
vous devez garder de la distance vous
devez porter le masque
il faudrait dire une bonne fois pour
toutes que on va sans doute vivre avec
ça tout l'automne tout l'hiver est sans
doute le début du printemps et que on va
pas être à la ddt à la tente tous les
quinze jours de telle ou telle stop and
go une telle annonce
il va falloir qu'on se dise que voilà on
va vivre concours
quand collectivement avec ça et les
vacances de la toussaint sont des
vacances qui sont souvent passés en
famille et on va souvent voir les
parents et les grands parents
là mon message il est encore plus fort
protégez vous protéger les vôtres fait
extrêmement attention